so we have 6x squared minus 120 X plus
600 equals 0 like always pause this
video and see if you can solve for X if
you could find the x values that satisfy
this equation all right let's work
through this together so this the
numbers here don't seem like outlandish
numbers they seem like something that I
might be able to deal with and I might
be able to factor so let's let's try to
do that so the first thing I like to do
is see if I can get a a coefficient of 1
on the second degree term on the x
squared term and it looks like actually
all of these terms are divisible by 6 so
if we divide both sides of this equation
by 6 I'm still going to have nice
integer coefficients so let's do that
let's divide both sides by 6 so if we
divide the left side by 6 divided by 6
divided by 6 divided by 6 and I divide
the right but side by 6 so if I do that
and clearly if I if I do the same thing
to both sides of the equation then the
Equality still holds on the left-hand
side I am going to be left with x
squared and then negative 1 20 divided
by 6 that is C 1 20 divided by 6 is 20
so that's minus 20 X and then 600
divided by 6 is 100 so plus 100 is equal
to zero divided by 6 is equal to zero so
let's see if we can factor if we can if
we can express this quadratic as a
product of two expressions and the way
we think about this and we've done it
multiple times if we have something if
we have X plus a times X plus B and this
is hopefully review for you if you
multiply that out that is going to be
equal to that equals 2x squared plus a
plus B X plus a B and so what we want to
do is see if we can factor this into an
X plus a and an X plus B and so a plus B
needs to be equal to negative 20 that
needs to be a plus B and then a times B
right over here that needs to be equal
to the constant term
needs to be a times be right over there
so can we think of two numbers that if
we take their product we get positive
100 and if we take their sum we get
negative 20 well since their product is
positive we know that they have the same
sign so they're both going to have the
same sign so they're either both going
to be positive or they're both going to
be negative since we know that we have a
positive product and since their sum is
negative well they both must both be
negative although you can't add up to
positive numbers and get a negative so
they most they both must be negative so
let's think about it a little bit
what negative numbers when I add to each
to the when I add them together I get
negative 20 when I multiply again I get
100 well you could try to factor a 100
you could say well negative 2 times
negative 50 or negative 4 times negative
25 but the one that might jump out at
you is this is negative 10 times I'll
write it this way negative 10 times
negative 10 and this is negative 10 plus
negative 10
so in that case both our a and our B
would be negative 10 and so we can
rewrite the left side of this equation
as I can rewrite it as X and I'll write
it this way it first X plus negative 10
x times X plus negative 10 again X plus
negative 10 and that is going to be
equal to zero so all I've done is I
factored this quadratic or another way
these are both the same thing as X minus
10 I could rewrite this as X minus 10
squared is equal to 0 and so the only
way that the left-hand side is going to
be equal to 0 is if X minus 10 is equal
to 0 you could think of this as taking
the square root of both sides and
doesn't matter if taking the positive or
negative square root or both of them
it's the square root of 0 0 and so we
would say that X minus 10 needs to be
equal to 0 and so X adding 10 to both
sides of this
you have X is equal to 10 is the
solution to this quadratic equation up
here